[Music]
guys may have an awesome relationship
but that doesn't mean they know
everything that is on their girls mind
there are some things that guys are just
better off not knowing about their girls
if you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and give this video
a big thumbs up girls want your ex
girlfriend to be beautiful when it comes
to access girls can get a little
sensitive about the subject of course
they don't want you to still find your
ex attractive but that doesn't mean they
want your ex to be unattractive all
together if your girlfriend is spying on
your ex are trying to see what she looks
like chances are she is seeing how she
measures up she also secretly wants her
to be attractive she knows if your ex is
hot that means your girlfriend is
probably hot as well girls check up on
their exes via social media every girl
is guilty of stalking their exes on
social media even the happiest
girlfriends are prone to see what their
ex is up to on Instagram this honestly
has nothing to do with you and
everything to do with her ego she just
wants to make sure that she is having a
better life than he is other times girls
are still friends with their exes and
it's really not a big deal girls
recognize hot girls at a party before
hot guys have you ever heard the same
girls dress for other girls well it's
true girls like to put emphasis on their
looks so they can impress other girls
because of this girls notice hot girls
at parties before they notice hot guys
but truth is girls want to see how well
they stack up against the competition
she secretly hopes other girls think
she's hot as well girls actually like
your flaws when it comes to your flaws
chances are your girl is falling in love
with them just like how men like girls
with flaws women think men with flaws
are unique whether it's a little bit of
gut or a gap in your teeth your flaws
make you you girls will pretend to need
help so you will do whatever they want
girls are very capable beings and she's
pulling a fast one when she keeps asking
you to do things for her this is simply
a way for her to see if she has control
over you girls will pretend to need help
so you will do whatever they want as
long as you don't mind being a little
used you should enjoy helping her out
girls no crying is blackmail from a
young age girls know the power of their
cry that doesn't mean that every time
they cry they aren't being sincere but
if it feels like she's crying just to
get attention it's because
she is girls know that crying is
blackmail and we'll use it as a weapon
against you
it may not seem fair but there is really
nothing you can do about it girls aren't
going to give up their best defense
system anytime soon
girls farts super loud in the bathroom
that's right she may seem prim and
proper when other people are around but
all girls are guilty of farting super
loud when they are alone in the
bathrooms just like guys girls enjoy the
release of a fart and it feels better to
not hold it in she may even run to the
bathroom just to fart so she doesn't do
it in front of you it may be stinky and
gross but it's the truth
girls aren't naturally hairless and
smooth if you think girls have naturally
silk smooth skin then you are sadly
mistaken
women have hair that grows everywhere
and it gets worse with age though you
may have seen her shave her legs you
probably don't know the half of it
thanks to societal norms women have to
wax their chins eyebrows sideburns in
pretty much every place you wouldn't
want the hair to be if she didn't keep
her hair removal routine in check and
you would think you were kissing him in
girls love it when you get a little
jealous it may not be one of girls
better traits but they love it when you
get a little jealous that doesn't mean
she wants you to be crazy jealous or get
physical curls just want to know you
care you may notice her paying more
attention to another guy in an attempt
to make you jealous she will know just
what to do to keep you on your toes and
she loves it when you take the bait
don't get too worked up though she just
wants your attention and if you'll
wanted girls know when you were cheating
women have something called women's
intuition and it's almost like a sixth
sense something in their gut alerts them
that something is not right this is how
they know when you are cheating and they
very rarely ignore the signs you may
think you are getting away with murder
but chances are she is on to you if you
are cheating your days are numbered
because she is already plotting how to
catch you in the act are you shocked by
any of these dirty secrets girls will
never tell guys react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
[Music]